witness the elusive massive giant
stingray
this monster was caught in crachit
Cambodia on April 1st 2008 offering
scientists a rare glimpse of a species
that locals estimate can grow to a
massive 1,000 pounds
if these rumors are confirmed the giant
stingray also known as a whip ray could
prove to be the world's largest
freshwater fish
little is known about the abundance or
habitat needs of the giant stingray
which inhabits the rivers of Southeast
Asia and northern Australia National
Geographic emerging Explorer Zeb Hogan
was called in to study this huge animal
as part of national Geographics mega
fishes project an effort to document the
world's freshwater giants